pour en parler nous sommes avec léonard
corti secrétaire général de
l'intersyndicale nationale des internes
bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france votre
mobilisation qui se poursuit donc
quel est le résultat aujourd'hui ça a
porté quelques fruits
de même alors nous les internes nous
sommes en grève depuis le 10 décembre et
on a eu quelques annonces qui ont été
faites assez rapidement après le début
de notre mouvement
le 15 décembre par à madame la ministre
clairement ces annonces elles ont été en
deçà de ce qu'on attendait
madame la ministre a fait quelques
propositions notamment sur le temps de
travail mais en paix en refusant un
décompte horaire de nos temps de travail
en proposant seulement des mesures pour
encadrer ce temps au sein des
établissements en obligeant les
commissions médicales d'établissement à
le présenter
mais clairement sur le fond de
revendications il ya eu quand même pas
mal de déception chez les internes ce
qui est ce qu'ils ont engagés à
poursuivre le mouvement jusqu'à
aujourd'hui quelle est la plus grande
qu'elles sont même allés plus grande
déception mais vraiment sur le temps de
travail en fait nous ce qu'on demandait
c'est un décompte horaire du temps de
travail parce qu'on estime que tant
qu'on n'aura pas ce décompte horaire
tellement ça sera très difficile de
connaître exactement combien de temps de
travail les internes et aujourd'hui on
sait par des enquêtes que ce ton travail
il dépasse largement le temps légal
pourquoi selon vous la ministre
justement ne veut pas entendre parler de
ce temps horaire à la corde ça coûte
trop cher en fait on comprend pas bien
on a eu que certaines réponses qui était
que ont vu qu'on était des futurs
médecins on n'avait pas besoin d'avoir
un temps de travail en cas d' encadrer
qu'on n'allait pas badgés finalement
comme d'autres professions le fond alors
que nous on a on a questionné les un
terrain on a questionné même deux
praticiens hospitaliers fameux des
médecins seniors à l'hôpital qui mais
peu sont prêts à mettre en place des
techniques alors il ya le badge mis à
plein de technique pour connaître
précisément le temps de travail les
internes sont prêts à faire cette
démarche là parce qu'ils estiment
qu'aujourd'hui toute façon c'est la
seule solution qui l'aurait ce pour
faire véritablement respecter le temps
légal le temps légal de l'internet ces
48 heures hebdomadaires
et aujourd'hui on est au delà des 55 à
56 heures hebdomadaires ce qui semble
étonnant c'est que effectivement
votre métier est à risque aussi pour les
patients c'est très important de ne pas
dépasser de ne pas trop tirer sur la
corde est ce que c'est un argument on
imagine que vous l'avez avancé qu'est ce
qu'on vous a répondu
finalement sur sur ça on ne répond qu'
il faut il faut prendre en compte cette
question finalement c'est là où on voit
une petite avancée du ministère c'est
qu'ils nous disent on a conscience que
le temps de travail d internet excessif
que ce temps travail excessifs nuit à la
formation et peut nuire comme vous le
dites à la qualité des soins et à la
sécurité des patients est en fait on
voit pas trop les solutions qui sont
proposées alors les différentes
solutions que j'ai dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure c'est par exemple présenter le
tantra et des internes en commission
médicale d'établissement mais mène à la
miss propose aussi des sanctions
financières pour les établissements qui
ne respectent pas le temps de travail
des internes ou bien de deux de faire
passer la certification par le respect
tente du temps de travail des internats
certification des établissements
mais tout ça c'est des mesures qui on va
voir on espère que ces dossiers vont
vont s'ouvrir déjà qu'on fasse un état
des lieux
mais on pense que ce sera insuffisant
pour faire vraiment respecté le ton
travail d internet parce que ça fait
effectivement très longtemps on parle de
ses problèmes qu'est ce qui coince le
plus c'est un manque de volonté
politique selon vous on est sans cesse
qui a pas d'argent dans les caisses mais
ce qu'on a vraiment envie de le trouver
selon vous on ne pense que c'est un
problème
plus qu'un problème d'argent c'est un
problème d'organisation fait de tout
l'hôpital c'est à dire que clairement et
c'est pour ça qu'on se mobilise le 14
février c'est pour nous il ya un lien
direct entre la dégradation de la
situation à l'hôpital public et la
dégradation des conditions de travail
des internes
finalement pourquoi les internes se
retrouvent à travailler de plus en plus
parce que ce qu'on voit c'est que depuis
une quinzaine d'années ça fait une
quinzaine voire une vingtaine d'années
que les internes etc d'alarmé sur le
temps de leur temps de travail excessif
est en fait depuis vingt ans on se rend
compte qu'on parle de plus en plus du
temps de travail des internes et de ses
excès mais on se rend compte que les
internes de travail de plus en plus
malgré ça il en fait pourquoi les
internes travail de plus en plus parce
que la situation à l'hôpital se dégrade
avec un manque de recrutement de deux
praticiens seigneur qui fait que les
internes se retrouve à se retrouve à
faire tourner les services alors que
c'est clairement pas leur rôle et leurs
fonctions avec un temps de formation
pour les internes qui se restreint et
qui du coup conduit les internats faire
plus d'heures pour rattraper leur temps
de formation qu'ils perdent au profit de
tâches qui sont des tâches non médical
des tâches non cliniques comme elle de
l'administratif en a fait une haie ont
une enquête justement qui montre que les
internautes passent de plus en plus de
temps dans un ordinateur ce qui est bien
la preuve qu'en fait ils ne font plus de
cliniques in souk où il s'occupe lui
plus des patients en tout cas ils font
ils font moins de temps médical
vous sortez des études il n'y a pas si
longtemps par définition quand vous êtes
interne aujourd'hui clairement qu est ce
qui vous pousse vous et vos collègues
allaient dans le public est ce que vous
craignez justement qu à terme est de
moins en moins de candidats pour les
hôpitaux publics
clairement le
chez les internes mais on le voit on
voit chez les seniors i en 2019 y avait
un tir des postes de praticiens
hospitaliers qui n'ont pas été pourvus
qu'ils ont été ouverts et non pourvus et
les internes voit vraiment avec beaucoup
d'inquiétude par exemple le mouvement
mené par le collectif inter hôpitaux de
démission de des fonctions
administratives d'un certain nombre de
nombre de seniors à l'hôpital public
série ça inspire pas confiance dans
l'avenir de l'hôpital et c'est vrai que
c'est aussi un message qu'on essaie de
faire de porter auprès de madame namyst
qui est que si elle n'arrive pas
revaloriser les conditions de travail
les perspectives d'avenir vraiment pour
les professions médicales au sein de
l'hôpital public
les internes vont s'en détourner le 14
février vous lisez nouvelle grande
journée de mobilisation qu'est ce que
vous allez faire pour vous faire
nouvelle fois tenté en tout cas entendre
mais tenter de se faire entendre sur
tout le terrain alors le 14 février
c'est une journée qui est qui a été
impulsée à l'initiative du collectif est
un terreau urgences et du collectif est
un terreau hôpitaux l'idée c'est de
faire un une manifestation suivie d'un
événement festif donc une manifestation
qui fera qui sera entre l'hôpital necker
et l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
normalement et qui donnera lieu à la fin
à un événement festif autour du thème et
j'aime mon hôpital public
l'idée c'est vraiment de d'associer là
population à cette manifestation nous le
message qu'on essaie de porter mais que
porte le collectif interrogeant c'est le
collectif et intérêts aux hôpitaux
depuis des mois déjà c'est de dire la
population préoccupée vous et venez au
chevet de l'hôpital public qui bientôt
ne pourra plus s'occuper de vous merci
beaucoup
léonard corti d'avoir été avec nous
secrétaire général de l'intersyndicale
nationale des internes merci à vous
merci maman vite